aujourd'hui la justice de notre pays est
en grande souffrance nous dépensons deux
fois moins pour la justice que
l'allemagne alors face à cette justice
noyer il faut un plan orsec il faut un
plan de sauvetage un plan de 5 milliards
d'euros une augmentation de 50% des
moyens de la justice avec le recrutement
de 16 mille agents aujourd'hui on a
entre 18 mois et deux ans de stock pour
la justice pénale pour la justice civile
pour la justice administrative moi je
veux l'impunité zéro
je veux que en cas de flagrant délit il
puisse y avoir des comparutions
immédiates
je veux que lier des sanctions des
peines planchers pour les
multirécidivistes violent je veux que
quand on s'attaque à une personnalité
qui a autorité eh bien on est un an de
prison ferme et que ce soit on peine
certaine ce que je veux c'est des
sanctions les sanctions efficaces le
travail d'intérêt général tu casses
tuerez pas tu as grèce qui indemnise ça
ça veut dire des retenues sur salaires
mais aussi des retenues sur allocations
sociales et puis je veux que les courtes
peines de prison soient exécutés parce
que évidemment il ya un caractère
parfois pédagogie de la prison mais il
ya aussi le fait d'éloigner les caïds
les voyous de leur quartier et de leur
victime donc ces courtes peines pour les
exécuter je créerai des prisons
provisoire dans lesquels on pourra
incarcéré pour des courtes peines des
détenus sous bracelet électronique et
nous devons construire vingt mille
places de prison supplémentaires
j'ajoute qu'il ya près d'un quart des
détenus qui sont étrangers en france je
souhaite que nous ayons des partenariats
avec leur pays d'origine pour qu'il
puisse aller exécuter leur peine dans
les prisons de leur pays d'origine je
travaillerai aussi sur la réinsertion
des détenus parce que qu'il faut lutter
contre la récidive si on veut lutter
contre la multiplication des
[Musique]